all right hear me out we we we've played
it safe in some of the genres all right
okay not not domestic girlfriend or rent
girlfriend a big [__] say Oro I'm
going to kill you a big [__] part of
the anime culture is the [__]
degenerates right it is it is a massive
it is a shows yeah ety shows degenerates
which ety
show High School DxD you want to say I
think maybe High School F I'm not even
see I I would have said High School the
de I would the I was like I don't know
if like I don't know if it's just me or
my generation I REM like High School of
the Dead but definitely up there if I
were to like think of what show started
like the rabbit hole down like the of
the Dead awoke an entire generation of
anime Watchers it was like oh [__] and
there were two two moments in particular
that stand out to me uh the two Cannon
events in my life one was watching High
School of the Dead and the second was
the toothbrush scene in N mon God that
that like that to me it just it started
a different time be the horny list
instead horny I could do a whole M
Rushmore ony anime but I'm saying it's a
big part of the anime commun is God
forbid anime News Network are not going
to put these [__] shows on their list
hey if we're going to put monari series
on there I ain't complaining I I don't
think monari deserves to be on there
it's it's too Jerry was like Jerry had
the in there he went I tried guys I
tried but I I would be happy to put it
would be an honor to put High School of
the Dead High School of the Dead I think
yeah uh cuz if we're talking especially
like mid 2000 anime like that was a show
that a everyone watched B everyone was
like I think pleasantly surprised
watching as well because I think a lot
of people again went into High School of
the day thinking oh it's a zombie anime
and then they were like why is my dick
hard so you know I think just like
subverting expectations and then also
just being one of the show that's so
almost memed to the point where like you
couldn't not be like at the time go up
to someone and be like have you watched
High School of the Dead you kind of have
to watch it it's a show that not many
people like bring up often but whenever
you do everyone only has positive things
to say about it even though it's it's
one where you're just like oh I
definitely don't want my mom to see this
but as soon as you bring it up they're
like yo that was [__] lit man it was
[__] great so if we want to be
different cuz that's what you want right
no I just yeah I mean High School dxt is
High School DxD is also up there sorry
sorry High School of the Dead sorry they
both have D's in them double both have
high
school um yeah I mean I think it's it's
a valid argument uh I think we can do
better though do better love
[__] I mean it was influential the OG
king of harms man it was influential the
OG king of harms what can I say like no
might not have aged well at least the
anime hasn't but you know it's the
manga's Aged well though the manga has
aged well I'm trying to think I'm Sur
you didn't say Gintama joery I thought
you right but I guess it's not Gintama
okay yeah as much as I love Gintama and
it's like always ranked highly on my
anime list it's just it's it's a
difficult it's a difficult anime to get
people into I feel because I feel
Gintama is an anime for anime fans you
know what I mean I watched four episodes
I had a hard time kind of getting into
it yeah it's it's very like you either
don't get it at all or you are
absolutely in love with it you know
there's no in the middle all right
influential I think uh kaiji because it
made a generation of gambling addicts uh
and that certainly influenced their
lives cuz it made gambling really cool
all right IAD don't you mean don't you
mean kakuru no no kaii is the better
gambling anime and everyone knows it and
anyone who says Kaki fuing WR kakuri was
highly influential it was so influ
people are still cosplaying you cuz it's
easy you you cuz you can buy it on
Amazon for 10 bucks you look up like Tik
Tock cosplay videos and it's like filled
with
you it's
$10 because you can get a red school
outfit that fits in a black wig it's too
easy to do uh that that show is capital
B for boring dude it's yeah I didn't is
like what the men watch when they want
to gamble but kaii is like kij is one of
those shows it's not going to be on
there by the way
yeah but that's K is the better anime K
is definitely the better anime but it's
one of those shows where it's like only
the people actually watched it rate it
you know what I mean cuz it's [__]
ugly and for some reason they only
released it in 720p yeah yeah I this my
it's the weirdest fact no other anime
did this but for some reason kaiji was
like 720p will do yeah why I think one
that in in that vein then I think one
that almost gets like uh overshadowed by
shows like kaiji or uh kakugi is like
death parade that is I mean that's
but every person I know who has seen
that is like rates it super highly
That's What I Call like Hidden Gem no no
yeah kind of Hidden Gem but it's it's
never someone's favorite show it's
always just like someone's like 10th
favorite show you know it's not it's
never the first one that pops into
someone's mind um so okay I can't
believe I'm about to say this Kon no
I can't I cannot believe I'm about to
say this he said it but he said it uh Mo
cute girls doing cute things is that was
also 2000 as [__] that is you know a
massive part of anime culture if it
wasn't for Kon bot of the rock wouldn't
be here say fate ah fate fate doesn't
deserve to be on there you know which
fate do I put down guys I have to pick
one seven of them entire series of
bankrupt half of Japan's Young
Generation look look look without Kon we
wouldn't have people having the worst
[__] takes on Twitter using a [__]
anime anime cute anime girl profile
started that also the mid 2000s mob blob
movement was all started from Kon and
that was like everywhere before the
isaki thing came in so wait what's on
our list again I we haven't put anything
on the Dragon Ball Aira Gundam AA and
attack ontan and attack on Titan and
Sailor Moon so a six already has six so
we're [__] and death note appar I
think deathe should be on there I
justed um okay so I I I just remembered
like Ghost and the shell was also
massively [__] influential as well
that's true but then the movie was kind
of me yeah yeah I know maybe the death
not movie was fantastic with the one
with Dam
defo the [__] are you talking about
great
mov I'm just S I mean he's so great all
right all right is there any other shows
you guys would like to bring up or shall
we try and start finalizing this
list um what about what about in the
sports
genre it's a it's pretty much going to
be only slam dunk in terms of
influential and that's mostly the manga
um there are influential like Sports
Anime like
highq um hadim oo is a fan favorite but
I don't think that's as influential but
I don't think a Sports Anime
can stand on the same caliber as some of
the other shows uh kroo
basket no I'm [__] with you freeone
have you heard of it goed
goed Yuri Yuri nice Jo my favorite
sports so good yeah your favorite sports
anime I mean I mean I don't know it kind
of feels like the seventh one will be
like just like one of the presidents you
don't know Mount Rushmore like who's he
yeah well well okay we got to think like
what other genre are we missing so we
have like we obviously have our Shen we
have our romance is there an influential
romance anime influential romance no I
don't no I don't I don't think there is
clad I mean I love it but it's not
codeos no no codeos is also kind of the
Mecha genre yeah it's kind of the Mecha
genre and it's also kind code gu for me
is also kind of in the same place as
like death parade where it's like people
will raid it but it's never like the
number one for most people except
Charlie yeah I stars for
furries I mean goed but I wouldn't put
it I still think JoJo could go on there
probably but it's kind of tough cuz the
the anime has had a lackluster previous
season yeah uh
like yeah I can't I can't are there any
other anime genres that we're missing
that's you can think of Nai you didn't
mention sport yeah we mention sport I'm
trying to think if there's anything else
obvious RC romcoms that's like kind of
like there there's no good comedy anime
that deserves to be up there um I don't
count jint get that [__] away from me
anime most recent amazing horror anime
that's not going to be up there um so
yeah I think we have our nominations
okay so let's start finalizing it so I
think we can all agree Akira yes
uh I'm fine with the list so far I think
it's a little safe but yeah okay so we
so so far we have Akira Gundam yeah
Evangelion yeah uh saor Moon Dragon Ball
yeah uh what else is there death note
and ATT tack on
time we can talk about death for
something else if you want
to I do
think cuz this is this's not going on L
there there's nothing you can say I'd
rather put a shell old on the on the
list than sort out online I mean I I I'm
I think out of everything the one that I
feel most strongly about is actually har
like I'm not putting har on the I would
I would put
har two 2 V one 2
one is that considered like SLI of life
or psychological yeah I mean's the
psycholog one slice of life I think
Slice of Life is harcke season
2 there's no way that you guys think
Harry belongs on there more than Death
Note no way I think in terms of
influence no it's not just influence
we're considering everything yeah
considering everything like I think I
think har he brought on a bigger
movement than death
no on a grand scale if we consider
everything Hari had a bigger impact on
anime because yes I think death no had
more fans but I think Hari was as
popular as Death Note back in the day at
least when they were in Japan I think
har was more popular than the thing that
gives The Edge is just how it has
popularized um the way a whole different
medium that's getting adapted uh for you
know whether you like that change or not
it was the Catalyst for it so yeah on
the record I I don't agree with this I
do not agree with yes we did it har we
did it Harry fans we got the
do I'm I think def is much more
influential but hey yeah I want to see
the Google Trends could har suzia versus
death note on Google Trends just
I just want an instant gratification
there's no way obviously death it's
going to be higher because it's more
normal it's more normal it's more for
the norm more reach more
influential some might say hey we don't
know the Google trans come in favor it's
more Norm we can we I guess the audience
can decide this then uh I can't wait for
Hari is not an anime for non-anime fans
that is
true think is why it's limited I think
Death Note appeals to the masses
and but I think in term of the general
like change and movement that are
brought to the anime fandom and the way
that anime is like created and marketed
I think har had more of an influence
than Death Note did har was a kindon
event for the anime industry yeah like
deathe was death note I think was only I
think Death Note was like propagated
purely because of all the other shows
that it came out alongside of especially
during sh and jump cuz that came out
during a golden period of sh and jump
also I just feel like K animation
deserves a place
list like KY animation one of the most
goated anime uh uh Studios of all time
and I think I think they deserve a place
in their list and which would you prefer
Hari or [__] Kon
neither I would rather make it a six
wonders
L actually there are only uh six wonders
in
anime sorry am I comparing it too uh
Death Note to Hari suzia or just yeah
you put har should come up just power
here well that was uh that was that was
pretty interesting it's uh pretty inter
I can't wait for the comments yeah yeah
prob death got shafted by [__] har
here death not death notes the unsaid
Eighth Wonder of the anime
worldall I Rush my
case well yeah clearly that's not even
like that's that was that's not even
shocking oh United Kingdom we do
worldwide uh for the past as as far as
it goes back and then
me if we're doing [__] Google friends
let's just name off the most popular
anime you know I'm sure oh let see there
we go see death node constantly more
popular never been a point in
time I mean we're not we're not talking
about purely popularity unless you know
in that case we would have indicative of
influence of it is it is but that means
uh we that means we should put basically
like Naruto up there Naruto for Naro
than Harris us a m i
wouldn't you know I'm pretty sure like
it be make a safe list and picking
literally picking all the nor show aha
har he was more popular than death not
at one point look at that for one month
look at that at one point the data
doesn't lie July 206 literally when har
he came out har he let's go
har was like all right you've had your
time look at that beautiful wait when
did the death anime come out actually
that's great 2007 oh yeah so wait whilst
it was like the the manga was happening
it was yeah I mean like death note was
shown and jump and pretty much any shown
and jump show or Manga is you can you
can literally Place death no with any
shown and jump show from this period and
will probably be the same